let's do some problems that deal with
equations and inequalities so let's
start with this problem two here so it
says define the variables and translate
the following expressions into
inequalities so see Part A a bus can
seat 65 passengers or fewer
so in Part A let's let let X be the
number bus can seat can see so the
number of people you can fit in the Box
bus we're gonna call that X and they're
saying that the bus can feet can fit 65
people or fewer so X so X has to be less
than or equal to 65 and we put that
equal there that less than or equal
because it could be 65 it doesn't say
definitely less than 65 it could be 65
passengers or fewer so that's why it's
less than or equal to be the sum of two
consecutive integers is less than 54 so
if you say X is first integer and then X
plus 1 is the next they're saying the
sum of these two is less than 54 so X
plus X plus 1 is less than 54 and if you
actually wanted to figure out what X is
what the first integer you could just
solve this inequality see an amount of
money is invested at five percent annual
interest let X be the amount of money
its invested at five percent annual
interest the interest earned at the end
of the year is greater than or equal to
two hundred fifty dollars so what's the
interest earned at the end of the year
it's the amount of money you invest
times your annual interest rate times
five percent or provide there's a
decimal with 0.05 so 0.05 or 5% tie
the amount of money invested that is
going to be greater than or equal to
this is the amount of interest earned
that is interest interest earned that is
going to be a greater than or equal to
two hundred and fifty dollars so that's
what we did we set up the problem we
into an inequality and Part D Part D you
buy hamburgers at a fast-food restaurant
a hamburger costs forty nine cents you
have at most three dollars to spend
right in equality for the number of
hamburgers you can buy so let's let
let's change it letters let's H be equal
to the number of hamburgers so the total
I'm going to spend is the number of
hamburgers times the amount for
hamburger times 0.49 that's the total
amount I'm going to spend and that can
at most be three dollars so it has to be
less than or equal to three dollars less
than or equal to three dollars so that
is our inequality let's do problem 4
here problem 4 check that the given
number is a solution to the
corresponding inequality alright Part A
here so the inequality is 2 times X plus
6 is less than or equal to 8x and
they're saying that X is equal to 12 is
a solution let's verify that so if you
put a 12 here in a different color if
this is a 12 and then this would be a 12
so you get 2 times 12 plus 6 so this is
2 times 18 is less than or equal to 8
times 12 8 times 12 is 96 2 times 18 is
36 so 36 is definitely less than or
equal to 96 so this X is equal to 12 is
a solution Part B
B we have 1.4 times Z plus 50.2 is
greater than 0.4 z and for the solution
that Z is equal to minus 9 negative 9 I
should say always C minus 9 the correct
wording is negative 9 so let's put a
negative 9 here so it's 1.4 they're
saying that that's one of the solutions
times negative 9 plus 5 point 2 is
greater than 0.4 times negative negative
9 and I'm just going to use the
calculator on this one just for the sake
of time you could do that on your head
if you like so we have on the left hand
side 1.4 times 9 times negative 9 that's
equal to minus 12 point 6 so this is
minus twelve point six plus five point
two plus five point two is equal to
negative seven point four so this
left-hand side is negative seven point
four and then they're claiming that that
is greater than this so I can do in my
head 4 times 9 is 36
I haven't when I put a negative sign
because the positive times a negative
and I have one number behind the decimal
point so this is saying negative seven
point four is greater than is greater
than negative three point six this isn't
true this isn't true if you draw a
number line right here so if this is
zero this is negative three point six
this is negative seven point four it's
less than negative three point six so
this is not true
I'll do it in a big red color that is
not true z is equal to negative nine is
not a solution of this inequality right
there it does not satisfy
that inequality Part C Part C they have
minus five-halves minus five-halves y
plus 1/2 is less than negative 18 and
they're claiming Y is equal to 40 as a
solution let's try that out so minus
five-halves instead of Y I can write 40
just to see if it works
plus 1/2 is less than -18 that's their
claim so 5 halves times 40 divide the
numerator divided by 2 so 1 it comes to
20 so that becomes minus 5 times 20 is
minus 100 plus 1/2 is less than -18 well
you could view this is 99 negative 99
and 1/2 negative 99 and a half you can
do that in your head if you like or you
could view this as 99.5 you're adding
0.5 to minus 100 is less than negative
18 which is definitely true this is more
negative than this is so this is correct
and then finally finally Part D let me
scroll down or let me clear some space
for myself
Part D D they're saying 80 is greater
than or equal to 10 times 3 T plus 2 and
they're claiming that t is equal to 0.4
as a solution let's try that out 80 is
greater than or equal to 3 times 0.4 3
times 0.4 plus 2 so that's saying that
80 is greater than or equal to 10 times
3 times 0 times 0.4 is 1.2 plus 2 or 80
is greater than or equal to 10 times
this is 3.2 or that 8080 is greater than
or equal to 32
which is absolutely right Saudi is also
a valid solution problem five problem
five the cost of a Ford Focus is 27
percent of the price of a Lexus gs450h
all right if the price of a Ford is
$15,000 so the Ford is is equal to
$15,000 what is the price of the Lexus
so they tell us at the Ford that the
Ford is equal to 27 percent of the price
of the Lexus is equal to zero point two
seven or 27 percent times the price of a
Lexus so we could just and I could write
F and L but I'll just write out the
words there
so the Ford we know is $15,000 so we
know that $15,000 is equal to 27 percent
zero point two seven times the price of
a Lexus so to figure out the price of a
Lexus we just divide both sides by point
two seven zero point two seven divide
this side by zero point two seven that
just becomes a 1 and so you have the
price of your Lexus is equal to $15,000
divided by 0.2 seven see what we get so
clear it with 15 one two three $15,000
divided by 0.2 seven is equal to 55
thousand five hundred fifty five dollars
and 55 cents so we will say 55 thousand
five hundred and fifty six dollars just
round up so this is equal to 55 thousand
five hundred and fifty six dollars so
you're spending a lot more on the Lexus
than you would on the Ford Focus it
better be a much better car finally
number six on your new job you can be
paid in one of two ways
all right you can either be paid so in
this way this is option 1 option 1
and let's write option two here option
two you can either be paid one thousand
dollars per month plus 6% Commission of
total sales so let's let let s is equal
to total sales so your first option
you'll be paid a thousand dollars per
month plus six percent of total sales so
on a monthly basis you'll be paid $1,000
plus six percent of total sales so plus
six percent times your total sales
that's option one that's right there you
can either create one thousand dollars
per month plus six percent commission of
total sales and then option two is
twelve hundred per month switch colors
option two I'll do it in yellow paid
twelve hundred per month so twelve
hundred per month plus five percent
commission on sales over two thousand
dollars
so plus let me scroll over a little bit
plus five percent of sales over two
thousand dollars so if my sales are s my
sales over two thousand dollars are
going to be s minus two thousand dollars
s minus two thousand dollars right if my
sales are let's say there's three
thousand dollars in a month the sales
over two thousand are gonna be three
thousand minus 2000 is gonna be one
thousand dollars over two thousand so
these are our two options let me let me
highlight that right over there and they
say for what amount of sales is the
first option better than the second
option and assume there are always sales
over two thousand dollars so they're
essentially saying okay this is always
going to be non zero right here so we
want to know the situation where the
first option is better better probably
meaning for me meaning that I'll get
more money so when is option one going
to be we give you to say greater than or
greater than equal to option two and
then we could solve this equation so
let's see what we can do the
first thing I might want to do is just
well let's let's do the first thing let
me subtract 1000 from both sides so if
you subtract a thousand from the left
hand side you're just left with 0.06 s
is greater than or equal to subtract a
thousand from the left hand side I'll
take the thousand from here you're left
with two hundred plus 0.05 times s minus
2,000 and then let's see I pi want to
multiply that out this is going to be
two hundred plus 0.05 s minus this
0.05 that's the same five percent that's
the same thing is one twentieth one
twentieth of two thousand that's 100 so
this is minus one hundred that times
that is one hundred I'm just
distributing this 5 percent or this
point zero five so that's the right hand
side of the equation and on the left
hand side we have zero point zero six
and we would just simplify the right
hand side a little bit we have 200 minus
100 so that just becomes 200 minus 100
we could just write it as plus 100 right
there so our equation is 0.06 is greater
than or equal to zero point is zero five
oh sorry this is 0.06 s is greater than
or equal to I don't want to lose that s
over there
0.05 s plus 100 now let's subtract 0.05
from s from both sides of the equation
so 0.06 minus 0.05 s is going to be 0.01
s is greater than or equal to I
subtracted this from both sides so it's
not going to be here anymore is greater
than or equal to 100 and now I just
divide both sides by 0.01 so 0.01 0.01
that becomes a 1 and then we are left
with
s to be greater than or equal to what's
a hundred divided by 0.01 that's 100
this is a hundred divided by this the
same thing as 100 divided by 1 over 100
which is the same thing as a hundred
times 100 a hundred times a hundred is
10,000 so option one is definitely
better for you if your total sales for
the month if your total sales for the
month if s is greater than or equal to
$10,000 if it's less than that
you're better with option two